[Music]
i have like 150 pounds to lose in
addition to battling depression and
anxiety
so i'm wondering how exactly to set kind
of some healthy boundaries while taking
care of myself while paying off all this
debt it sounds to me like you're
drowning
[Music]
hola mayama one this is the dr john
deloney show we're so glad you're here
so glad you're here talking about mental
health education relationships
love loss and all those things they sing
about in the 80s metal ballads if you
want to be on the show go to
johndaloni.com
ask or give us a shout and leave a
message at 1-844-693-3291
super cool
super cool
so i get notes and cards and letters and
um owl telegrams or pigeon telegraph i
don't get any of those i just
i don't whatever people let me know
through the internets mostly
that they love the show they love
telling people about it and that there's
always fun trying to describe this show
because it's like a mental health show
and it's a
show about like how to live better lives
it's a show about marriage and
relationships and dating and sex and
whatever
but also there's like a lot of diarrhea
jokes and a lot of inside baseball and a
lot of movie lyrics like how do we
describe this thing so the team here is
group of incredible ones and zeros kids
like they're great at uh
videoing and i know there's words for
this stuff and editing
and all of those things they created the
greatest
show trailer of all time it's so
great it
i watched it and i cheered here's how
good it was i showed my wife and i've
never sent an episode ever to her ever
why
she doesn't super care for it but hey i
send her this
and she watched it and she goes hmm
that's that's really good
that's like she brought like uh like a
high school marching band into our
living room and just started banging
things around and
like that was a celebration parade in my
home and she said that looks pretty good
it passed my wife test it's really great
if someone says hey what's this show
about or you want to send this to
somebody this is the key so check it out
here it is the new show trailer to the
dr john dolone show
so what's the show about oh man
that's hard brother what's up hey what
are you doing this is john with the dr
john dolone's show what's happening we
say the show's about mental health and
relationships how to live a well life
listen take yourself out to dinner it is
rare that i hear a new one and that's a
new one so well done so the show can go
anywhere at any time on today's show we
talk to a woman who's in love with a
hypochondriac and it's so hard to a dad
who's trying to teach body positivity to
his young daughters dealing with big t
trauma and family history to a sister
whose brother-in-law has screwed up
everything and we talked to a young mom
whose husband keeps making sexual jokes
around the kids whoa stay tuned
people ask me all the time man how'd you
learn how to do this to take those calls
and get to it real fast and make some
jokes and bring the room up the truth is
i've been doing that a long long time i
got two phds i've been doing this for a
couple of decades and i'm still learning
every day still trying to figure it out
as i walk alongside people
the guests are incredible they're
fantastic so it's fun to have guests man
who have done a bunch of fancy stuff i
love it
the heart of this show is callers just
like you
yeah i mean my dad was angry growing up
he never
your dad is intentionally disregarding
your requests for how you can best be
loved yeah and that disregard is
violence i don't want to try to take the
kids from her but i also feel like i'm
responsible for their safety as their
dad all right so listen to me carefully
okay yeah your your instinct is right
and i heard you say it at the end there
and i love your heart i don't want to
take
these kids from their mother
and what i would say to you is she is
screaming for somebody to please take
these kids for me before i hurt them
have you ever heard me lie to anybody
no
okay i'm not starting today it's not
your fault
[Applause]
[Music]
you cannot do life alone you can't heal
from hurt on your own and that's what
this shows for me and if you will put in
the work you'll give me a call you'll do
the hard work you will change your
family tree and it starts with you
deciding you're worth being well
all right so there it is that's it it's
pretty rad and thank you for checking it
out
please subscribe to the show the show's
continued to grow so much i'm so
grateful for you uh subscribe to the
show whether it's on podcast whether
it's on youtube you can go to
youtube.com
johndaloney and you can send that show
trailer out to everybody put it on the
internets and it will
cycle out there and do what things all
the internets do whatever so let's go to
our first call let's go to
christina uh right down the street
christina in nashville tennessee
what's up christina
hi dr john thanks for taking my call of
course how are you
i'm doing well thank you how are you
remarkable so what's up how can i help
wonderful
um well so before i dive into my
question let me just give a quick
background um i'm a person who's dealt
with
major anxiety in the past started nine
years ago
when i was pregnant with our third child
and start then i had to go on medication
then i've been through a lot of therapy
and got to the point where really i feel
like i was able to rewire my brain and
just learn all the things i got your
book um
redefining anxiety and it was kind of
after i'd gone through this process and
it was just like yes yes yes this is
totally
the pathway to freedom from that um
even went through covid without
spiraling um from anxiety which was
amazing so i was kind of surprised
recently when the war with ukraine
started it just
kind of sucker punched me and took me
back to some of those major
places of anxiety
but i guess what my question is is
i feel like a lot of my anxiety used to
be about
um
things that weren't a real possibility
um
but with this war i feel like um they're
more like rational fears if that makes
sense
and so my question is um how does a
rational person
prepare for
potentially grim outcomes or a future
without going off the deep end because i
feel like that can happen really quickly
um
and because of my history you know of
let's move to the country let's store
guns let's store food let's just go way
off the decent you know
where where's the middle ground and um
yeah that's that's my question so
christina do you realize by articulating
the question like you just did
how far
you've grown
yeah
that's no i'm just
work you have done i know you're
grateful for the work you have done is
incredible
because what you you just articulated
perfectly
a real world example of
my body's feeling this
i know reality's here
how do i how do i deal with the gap
between the two
yeah dude and i don't want to fill it up
with guns and meats full of freezer and
bullets and you know thinking
underground bunkers and so what do i do
with that gap
dude you are so far down the road it's
incredible what you've done is you've
created a new life for yourself and for
your family
so um the ukraine thing did this to me
but before we go down this road i blamed
ukraine
and it is real the war is real the
potential for spillover is real the
connection like the
playbook if you if you look back in
history at some of the other major wars
like like it all tracks right
right but if i'm honest with myself
that was
simply the match
that lit the kindling and gasoline that
i'd set up over a period of time so do
you have major life stuff going on
well i'm pregnant with our fifth child
so i know i've got the hormones
forget the hormones number one i can't
i'm not i'm not a hormone doctor so i
can't speak to that in two i'm not gonna
talk about that cause i'll get in
trouble
but
but you're having another kid
yeah so you at what number
five
you have a thousand kids
pretty much
wow okay so you've got four how what are
the ages
um twelve ten eight then jump down to
two and here's the buddy
and here's the buddy
we had you because we had dreams we had
you because
this because
it was it seemed it seemed smarter than
some sort of doodle right
um
so
okay so my guess is
that your body has a narrative and the
narrative can
speak to
any number of things
but a with a baby comes a lot of stress
it comes stressed on your marriage it
comes stress on your physical body
your you have memories of when your body
is
for a year or more or two years is not
your own and if you had a 12 and 10 and
an eight your body wasn't yours for six
or eight years
right right it's always it's it's a
utilitarian and then you got some
husband pawing at you like it just beca
it's not yours right and how do i find
myself
that is a recipe for an anxious alarm to
go off
um we're not safe we're not okay we're
not safe we're not okay so then you fast
forward you get your life back you start
healing
and a lot of the healing feels like i'm
doing all this hard work which you are
but also your life is flattening out a
little bit
you and your husband get in some sort of
rhythm you got a house full of three
kids and now
you have a covet baby which gave you a
great distraction
it did now you've got a
potential
world war iii buddy baby right
yeah and so here we are
so the first thing i want you to do when
you start feeling anxious now
is i want you to ask your body what are
you trying to protect me from are you
trying to what are you trying to do what
are you trying to tell me
and it could be any number of things i
blamed the last month or two a lot on
um
ukraine stuff
the reality is
for the last couple of months i've
isolated myself
i've not hung out with other people
and i am a guy who teaches about
relationships for a living
and i've all but i i can't tell you a
time i've hung out with just a group of
guys
months i've been on the road all over
the place the second thing is i just put
a book out
and i'm about to
and i am feeling a sense of pressure
that i've never understood before i've
never even come close to this right and
it's like being i'm it's like a nude
photo i would much rather knew it's not
that's not an impressive photo
but i think i would rather that than
this book because it's so exposing okay
so i blamed ukraine but the reality is
i've created an ecosystem that has kept
me from being safe so i would challenge
you to go back and look at where am
do i have my weekly
meeting with my girlfriends to me and my
husband have a a time every every day
every week that we are connecting
together
not sexually disconnecting it right so
all you hear i'm saying like where can i
go back to these fundamentals and basics
most of the time
we've got we get off those things and so
look back at your life tell me tell me
where we are on that track
yeah i mean so i'm a homeschool mom i'm
also my kid so by nature that creates
kind of a
isolating environment of sorts i mean
we're very well connected but still
homeschooling is super isolating
yes
yes and no i mean it by nature it is we
do have a great community of people but
um i did go through of course the first
trimester of being
isolated because i was so sick and in
bed and i don't think i've reconnected
like we were before that happened did
the shame fairy show up
and remind you how much of your kids
lives you are missing and god just get
up and your husband's going to get
annoyed and
yeah that's i mean that's a really hard
season when you feel pretty useless
you're just laying there like a blob
um
that's such a lovely image that you've
concocted of yourself christina you're
not just laying there like a blob
not almighty so here's what i want you
to do i want you to and i'm gonna
address the second half of your question
because it's really important i want you
to
tell your husband hey i want to
reconnect
and i have felt out of my body and
here's some of the stories i've been
telling myself that's the language i use
in my house story i'm telling myself is
this
i got that from the great brene brown
and it just saved my marriage okay
um but tell them here's the story that
i'm just a blob laying around that i'm
this that i'm only useful for educating
these dumb kids while you're offering
like and here's a couple of things i
need i need you to hold my hand we're
not doing it i need you just or maybe we
are like whatever you need but i need
physical touch again i need you to do
the bed times twice a week i need to
once in once a week go with my
girlfriends we're just gonna go be silly
and i'm gonna watch them drink wine
whatever the thing is
but plug back into the
life-giving practices and generally
speaking the alarms will begin to wind
themselves down
okay and if they don't then talk to your
ob gyn about say hey when i go through
pregnancy um i experience some
significant anxiety and they'll walk
through you just like last time and it's
not a
i mean you're not failing anything
that's awesome now you have a name for
it and it's you can go right to the
source
that's all good
the second thing is and you asked a
great question how do you be rational
during times of irrationality
right beautiful question
remember that anxiety is not a rational
response
it comes from the irrational part of our
brain the part of our brain that just
says you will stay alive at all costs
and in fact when those alarms go off it
unhooks or unplugs the rational part of
our brain
which is why my wife went to visit some
friends in missouri that happens to be
the place
where i've bought meat in the past
now i buy um i get my stuff i get my
meat shipped from
greensbury farm i love all the
greensbury crew they're incredible they
send stuff but i told my wife hey go
ahead and grab another 150 pounds
of at this boys ranch of just beef
and she said no
yes we're not we're not doing that we
have incredible
seafood and beef that's shipped to our
home now and we've got so much in our
freezer that right so i had i found
myself it sounded rational it sounded
smart but i realized oh this is coming
from another part of my brain which
leads me to this
in moments of irrational
you train yourself
you
pre you set up a foundation that you're
okay and you have other people
so here's the quick path here okay
i'm gonna train myself to
only spend a certain amount of time on
the internet
so that when something for real happens
i've got capacity
i'm gonna train myself to be intentional
about looking around and saying i've got
a great
i have i greensbury sends food to my
home
i'm okay we have a giant garden for our
vegetable needs we are good
i've got a grocery store we are fine i'm
gonna practice that so that when my
brain spins out i've got like i've got
thoughts i can lean back on
i'm not going to absorb
all the news and the this and the
youtube channels where they're just not
telling you the truth i'm not doing that
okay
and i'm going to
have a foundation of exercise and taking
care of myself and meeting with my
friends and the final one is i'm going
to have people in my life that i
go is this true
that's real is that fair that's huge
yeah yeah and that's the conversation
i've had with my husband i said you know
i feel like these are i have a million
ideas of how we can prepare
and i said but i just really want to see
if there are any that resonate with you
because
you're not mess you know you don't get
messed with with this whole anxiety
thing like he's so level he's just like
this level anchor oh you married so well
so here's a here's the here's the
statement i would pass along in your
house
i would come up with two different
statements
from this point forward i'm going to
start saying the story i'm telling
myself is
and when you're seven months pregnant
and you wake up and you can't move and i
want you to tell him the story i'm
telling myself is is that i'm not pretty
and you're not gonna love me say it out
loud keep the secret and let it i mean
don't keep the secret let it out say it
and let him respond to that
the second one is
i'm gonna start asking you is this real
i'm just gonna ask you is this real
and you can go he can go no it's not and
you will commit to learning to trust him
and that sounds hard is it real
um is world war iii happening is this
real
maybe
but there's not a lot we can do about it
in asheville tennessee right now
we can a b and c and just so we're clear
if there's nuclear bombs falling from
the sky your backyard garden's not going
to be a huge hit right so we'll we'll
solve that problem for another time
but is it real and this is the story i'm
telling myself those two things can
really reconnect you when things around
you are irrational and you're trying to
stay anchored in
reality good
for you i'm so proud of you christina
you're amazing we'll be right back
hey john deloney here i talk about how
important sleep is for your mental
health all the time on my show i was
just talking about it with my producer
kelly she told me she's normally burning
up at night and her husband's always
freezing i bet that sounds familiar
right but they got a dream cloud
mattress a few weeks back and for the
first time in almost 20 years they're
both sleeping comfortably through the
night and she's being nicer to me at
work good folks i can't say this enough
prioritizing sleep is one of the best
things you can do for your mental health
and listen good sleep starts with a
world-class mattress and dream cloud my
partners in sleep are making it easy
they're running their biggest offer ever
exclusively for our listeners 499
dollars in accessories and an additional
250 dollar cash discount that's a total
of 749 dollars in accessories and
savings i'm talking pillows mattress
protector luxury sheets all of it you
heard it from me and even from kelly and
about twenty thousand five star reviews
online
you gotta get dream cloud sleep
mattresses go to
or
dreamcloudsleep.com
and enter promo code deloney to get your
new mattress
all right we are back box of cracker
jack let's go to ashley in omaha what's
up ashley
hi dr john how are you good how are you
good awesome what's up
so my question is i am on baby step two
i'm paying off debt all right so
let me pause right here for our
listeners who don't know what that is
she's following the ramsey solutions get
out of debt plan which is a seven step
the baby steps we call it um step one to
save up a thousand bucks and step two is
pay off all of your debts smallest to
largest except for
your mortgage and so you are in baby
step two are you grinding it
i'm grinding it um how much debt you got
i have about thirty thousand dollars in
debt what is it
in loan
student loans
right oh man all right so you're
grinding it
so i'm grinding it and i'm killing it
um
my question and my concern though is
that i'm starting to run into some
health issues physical mental health
and
uh i have like 150 pounds to lose in
addition to battling depression and
anxiety
so i'm wondering how exactly to set kind
of some healthy boundaries while taking
care of myself while paying off all this
debt hmm
how do we get from seven-year-old ashley
to here
you've got a lot going on in your heart
oh goodness yes i do it was it was hard
for you to say i've got 150 pounds to
lose and mental health challenges
that was hard to say out loud yeah that
was really a brave thing i could hear in
your voice
walk me from
seven-year-old ashley tilnow
uh seven-year-old ashley
let's see
seven-year-old ashley was just a child
always kind of struggled with her weight
always being made fun of
um
i've struggled with my weight since i
was little but i guess the big like
weight challenges started when i was in
high school okay
when you get you get a childhood of
you're not beautiful and we're making
fun and i can't believe you're wearing
that and all the noises and mean awful
things that elementary middle school
kids say each other
and yeah not only that but i'm also on
the autism spectrum to kind of make
things a lot worse absolutely right so
then you've got
connection challenges connecting with
other people and that makes it even
worse good grief man you got a lot
do you have a supportive network
i do
mom and dad's still in the
picture mom and dad are very much still
in the picture
you said that though it's not i very
much still have a tumor
are you are you glad they're in your
life or no oh i'm i'm glad that they're
in my life um it's just kind of yeah
that was a bad question that was a bad i
didn't ask that question
um
if you sat down with him tonight and
said i'm going to embark on
four big things at once i'm going to
lose 150 pounds i'm going to pay off
everything i own
i am going to
ultimately land a new job
and i'm going to
take control of my mental health
would they say would they get tears in
their eyes and say
you will have two cheerleaders one
running ahead of you and one running
behind you and we've got your back on
this deal
oh absolutely they would
yeah okay so why are they making your
life hard right now
um well it's hard for me right now just
because i live with them but i've also
had to step up
as a role the caregiver for my mom
oh gosh you're also a caregiver for your
what does that mean
um so she
has some health issues right now too or
she can hardly walk and they're looking
at
potential surgery in the future so i've
been having to kind of take more care of
her and do stuff
around the house for her and my dad
how old are you
i'm 30.
why has this become your job to be their
caretaker
i figure i'm not married i don't have
kids
i figure
that you know i'm their daughter and
they want what's best for me and i just
want to
take care of them and just certain
things that i've seen with my
experiences in my life i've come to that
decision that i'm okay with being their
caretaker
hmm
it sounds to me like you're drowning
sounds to me like you're slowly
suffocating
i do feel like i'm suffocating yeah
you may have convinced yourself or
forced yourself um but as the great
vander kulk says your body's keeping the
score
and there's something codependent
there's something
um
unhealthy about the relationship and
interaction here
and
wanting to take care of your mom is a
beautiful wonderful thing
but if you do it and you die in the
process you've not helped
yeah
it sounds like you've lived a life of
i'm trying to disappear
i'm going to hide in plain sight i'll
hide behind my weight i'll hide behind
my fill in the blank
and this is a way you can help even
though helping
is killing you
what i'd love to see you do i'd love
love to see you look in the mirror and
say what do i actually want out of this
one crazy life
that's exactly how i feel
so can i ask you what do you want
like snap your fingers and you're down
150 pounds
and you owe nobody anything nothing
and you've got a new car that you paid
for with cash it's not new it's like a
2019 or whatever
what would you do
oh gosh what would i do
if i was deaf free and if i had all the
things in the world
can i challenge you real quick
sure sure
the way you just said all the things in
the world makes it sound like it's
cinderella
and it's not
this is just getting your life back
this isn't a fantasy it's not a myth
this is right in front of you
and you my sister ashley
are worth laughing and being loved and
feeling good when you wake up and your
knees not hurting and your neck not
hurting and every time you get that
email from
sally mae your heart drops again
when your boss treats you like crap and
you think i'm i'm worth more than you're
worth all of that and this is not a
pixar movie
this is your life
what would you do
what would you do
um
i don't know i mean
i've never really
thought that far in advance
okay
i bet if you and i spent an hour or two
together
we could you could walk me back through
some things that you think are pretty
normal about how you grew up and how you
were treated
and that i would probably be looking at
you with my mouth wide open
you've seen and experienced a lot
haven't you
yes you have
and people have hurt you haven't they
so the
heart the hard path here is
saying this stuff happened
and yet i'm worth more so
so much more
yeah
so here's how you prioritize your health
you look in the mirror today and you say
i'm worth feeling good
i'm worth my dad getting up and he can
help his wife
because he's a grown man
my mom has struggles and we can
negotiate i might be able to help but
i'm going to make a plan to at least
consider moving out
i'm going to continue to pay off my
debts in the baby steps way the same way
i'm going to be about changing the way i
treat my body because i'm worth being
loved
and right now you hate yourself and you
treat your body in a similar way is that
fair
it's very sure okay no more today
i'm not gonna let anybody hate ashley
because ashley's awesome
because you've got a great great heart
and nobody's giving you any tools to
show the world how that thing works
okay
okay i think after 30 years i think it's
going to be very very difficult to
impossible to do this on your own you've
been in counseling you said
yes
has it been effective or no
i'm guessing not
not really and i'm trying to find
another counselor okay
so i'm gonna do a couple of things for
you today okay
today is just the start today is when we
turn the lights on okay
and your homework assignment is this i'm
going to trade you a lot of cool stuff
for your homework assignment fair
that's true
your homework assignment is i'm going to
write ashley a letter
and it's going to have three parts to it
part number one
here's what happened
part number two
owning where we are right now
i owe 30 000 bucks in student loans
probably for a degree i'm not even using
i'm 30 and i live with my parents
um we didn't even talk about your
romantic situation or anything like that
i am dealing with a highly codependent
set of parents who are expecting this
and that and i've just talked to myself
into x y or z and my body's falling
apart on me and i and my mental health
is is really struggling i'm isolated and
alone
and the third part of this letter is
going to be you saying
here's what this could look like
because if you don't have a place that
you're going you're not going to get
anywhere
if you don't have a picture of i want
you to dream
as clear as possible
the house will look like this the job
will look like this
the person i'm dating will look like
this the car will look like this my bank
account will look like this and i'm not
doing this in some like
manifest and that's nonsense i'm saying
you've got to have a picture that you
are going to walk towards
and you saying i've never even thought
about that
you're worth a beautiful picture and if
you will do that i want you to um write
this down and i want you to either mail
it to me or email it to me okay that's
your accountability cool
okay that sounds good for that i'm gonna
do a couple of things i'm gonna give you
a year subscription to ramsey plus
okay
that comes with the
the
the ramsey solutions app that for
tracking every dollar app that tracks
all of your expenses it's everybody
around here uses it it's incredible it's
the best one on the market
um it also has all of the financial
piece videos that walks you through all
the baby steps if you actually want to
get out of debt
and it's got all kind of other stuff in
there tons of
encouraging things questions all that
kind of stuff you got to use it though
but i'm going to send it to you and give
you a year subscription okay and
i'm going to send you a copy of my new
book own your past change your future so
we're talking about you gotta own what
happened own reality and then make a
plan for what comes next and that book
will walk you step by step by step
through it okay the third thing i'm
gonna send you is my friend ken's book
paycheck to purpose
i want you to start dreaming about what
kind of work you can contribute to in
this world
and maybe it's taking care of your mom
but if it's taking care of your mom then
your dad's gonna pay you a salary
okay
okay you're not gonna be a free
stay-at-home nurse for your family
[Music]
okay
cool that sounds good in my hope the
next time i talk to you you are six
inches taller
not in reality but in the way you talk
to and look at and love ashley
will you say that out loud i'm worth
being loved
i am worth being loved and i can't wait
to call you back after i've done all
this and give you an update yes ashley
i love it i love it we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
betterhelp is online therapy that offers
video phone even live chat sessions with
your therapist you don't even have to
see anyone on a camera if you don't want
to it's more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours today dr
john daloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month so decide to invest in
yourself you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 percent off that's
betterhelp.com
all right hey we are back i want to
touch back real quick on that last call
um she called and said hey i'm out of
debt and how do i deal with my health
and obviously we the the conversation
got much much deeper
um but that is
again for those of you if you don't know
my boss is dave ramsey i coached the
show with him um he
he's
been on a crusade to
get people to live lives
not in debt
for years and years and decades and
decades
in the new book i talked about i i've
been interested in the psychology of
debt and this idea that
a cornerstone of mental health the
cornerstone of being well is autonomy
freedom
and i've come to believe in fact i'm
partnering with the research one
university i think i've talked about the
show to do this study because i'm going
to get some data behind it but i've come
to believe
that you cannot have
mental health
physical health
if you owe people money
and here's why
if you owe people money your body knows
that you are not safe because you do not
have autonomy you don't have freedom the
bank owns you
the car lease you can't stop working
you can't deal with a death in the
family you can't deal with a any sort of
margin because
next month that payment shows up and
next month that payment shows up in the
month after that and the month after
that
and so there's this
widening gap in
our mental and physical health
and i've never seen anybody connected to
death and i f to debt and i think it is
intimately linked and so i talked about
this in the new book by the way it's the
last week for pre-order last week the
book is selling like great dude i'm so
grateful so grateful so blessed last
week for pre-order own your past change
your future in that book i talk about
debt
and it's this story that we've told
ourselves and this is a new story a
brand new story just just a few decades
old that debt will save us
personal debt used to be a curse the end
of time the idea of spending more than
you earned not to mention significantly
more was insane
it was irresponsible everybody knew it
debt was slavery it was a strategy for
trapping entire segments of a population
and everybody knew it and by the way it
still is
it is a
planned way to trap a population of
people why do you think your phone
companies want you on a payment plan on
your phone
because you never ask how much it cost
and they can charge you more for it
and they will keep you going and keep
you going and keep you going until the
phone's about dead because they have
their screw you button that they hit
every two years i don't know how it
works but it just ends the phone and
then you got to get another one
when i went in and bought mine with cash
every time every time the person says
i've never had anyone try to buy it with
cash i said i just don't want to owe you
all money
i want this to be my phone not a phone
that i'm just kind of getting from y'all
and that's just one one tiny tiny
segment
sometime after world war ii the story
began to change debt became seen as a
tool or an opportunity store credit
credit cards personal loans they all
popped up in general sentiment the
general sentiment turned into why wait
until tomorrow when i can have it today
we're talking 50 to 100 years 50 to 70
years this is not a long time in the
world history
and you fast forward today and working
now to pay for something you ate last
month is normal
modern households with at least one
credit card carry over eight thousand
dollars of credit card debt from year to
year
that's turned into budgetless living
self-disciplineless living
owing people money is crippling it
causes anxiety and depression which are
about a lack of control and autonomy as
we talked about
in the book i unpacked this story and
many other ones but listen
if you're struggling with anxiety or
mental health
if you're struggling with i'm out of
control a great place to start
is
who owns me
who owns me
and that can be my mother-in-law
that can be toyota financial services
that can be an abusive spouse
a toxic work environment
or my my
mortgage
where am i not
free
that usually is the
the pulsing alarm for your anxiety
so on your pass change your future go to
john delonia.com check it out let's take
let's let's get one more call in oh
i didn't know it was in oklahoma fine
what's up kyle in oklahoma
hey john how are you i was great until i
had to call an oklahoman but such i'm
just kidding how's it going man at least
it's not a houstonian right boo
if dude if h town would have been
awesome no i yeah when you're in texas
when you grow up in texas oklahoma is
basically southern canada and it's well
yeah
uh most of
al qaeda live so it's all good so what's
up dude
hey um so my wife and i have been
married for about five years we each
have a child from a previous life
relationship
and we've got a foster daughter as well
um
calling about our middle son
he's my stepson my wife's biological son
but um
i guess it was about four months ago
he was in his last week before christmas
break and his father was arrested for
child abuse
we got a phone call from dhs while he
was at school
and probably spent it was probably a
week before we even had a chance to talk
to his father
he just kind of said you know the
lawyer's advising that you know cut off
contact
with his son for right now
while they're doing their investigation
and whatnot and uh i guess our question
is
two part really it's do we kind of bring
this up to our eight-year-old son and
let him kind of know what's going on or
do we wait for him to start asking
questions and then just what kind of
words do we use when we're trying to
explain what happened here to him yeah
he's the little boy's lucky to have you
that's awesome well thank you
um and thanks for being proactive man
what a mess so is it physical sexual
abuse uh physical abuse um our son's two
stepsisters weren't involved our son
wasn't involved but i mean obviously
he's been going over there in that kind
of
environment yeah so so um
broad recommendation
every kid needs the bathing suit talk
the talk about adult touch and kid touch
and private parts and what's good touch
and what's not good touch and the only
people on all of the earth that will
ever touch your body
or they can ever see parts of your body
are a doctor and mom and dad every kid
needs that so that's sexual abuse
and a safe place to mom and dad need to
not say things like uh and again i'm
teaching to the audience here not to you
um but every mom and dad don't say now
if anything happens you just come tell
us okay that's not how that works
parents have to engage that conversation
because the shame is so overwhelming for
a child right so that's sexual abuse
99 chance your son has seen this if not
experienced it is that fair uh yeah
that's more than fair yeah okay
so i think um it's a very honest direct
not graphic conversation
that lets him know because what he's
going to do is he's going to slowly
start to put together that he's not
seeing dad and y'all are going to be the
bad guys
right
and
all kids
understand that they are both mom and
both dad that that's part of them
and so this conversation is gonna be not
that your dad did this awful evil thing
because to an eight-year-old then that
means part of me is awful and evil
it's gonna be i'm sorry it is that he
did an evil thing not that he's awful
and evil
right okay so because we're not gonna
connect identity to this eight-year-old
little boy because he's gonna say well
then i'm capable of this type of evil
it's going have you all had
conversations about abuse your son has
suffered in the past
uh
no and up till i mean this we didn't
really have reason to suspect it i mean
we knew dad was you know kind of
short-tempered
and things like that this was pretty out
of character for him okay
so did he um
put into context did he shake kids did
he punch a kid like what happened throw
a kid up against the wall
yeah i i don't know i know mom um our
son's stepmom so dad's wife works night
shift and kind of all the story we got
was basically she came home the girls
had bruises on them
um
she sent him to school like that and
then the the school got involved and we
really hadn't had a chance to talk to um
his dad and stepmom about you know we
didn't we don't really have their side
of the story okay um stepmom
should also not to be
permitted to be around those kids either
ever again well
yeah they're uh they're actually going
through a divorce so that's but
that's great but she doesn't need to be
around those kids
the fact that she didn't ring the bell
that she pawned that off on the school
is nonsense those girls looked to her
for help and she didn't provide it the
school had to be able to turn out
she may or may not be
in contact with the kids right now i
don't know well i hope she's not i hope
she has no access to those kids at all
um because she failed him she let him
down right
she got charged too so i mean i'm sure
there's something in place there so my
conversation with my eight-year-old
would be this
um
we need to have a serious conversation
with you and i would do it in a place
that's safe
and i would do it as much as possible
with physical touch involved okay
um
i would
the conversation would be very short and
very direct and very honest which is
your dad got in trouble
he may have we're not sure but he may
have hurt some people when he got angry
and we are going um
we're not going to be able to see him
for a little while
and
i would let my son ask any questions say
i don't have a lot of answers
we don't know everything for sure but we
do know is
he's in trouble right now
and your sisters are safe and the police
are involved and when we know more we
will let you know
if it comes out that this is true and
this happened your dad beat them up
etcetera
then
the conversation will be an age
appropriate
um not using words like abuse and
violent it will be
your dad hit your little sisters with
the closed fist on their legs and that's
never okay for a grown-up to hit them
and so they're not allowed to be around
him anymore and right now
we're not gonna allow you and i think
it's important for him to know that you
are setting boundaries even though he's
gonna hate you for him for right now
okay okay yeah we are protecting you
because that's our job and the the
police officers or the courts whatever
one he's going to understand um have
said that daddy can't be around kids
anymore and i know this is so so sad
your daddy does love you
very very much and he's getting the help
that he needs et cetera and we'll go
down that road
but i think it's important for him not
just to dad suddenly start ghosting him
it's that daddy got in trouble
and he did some things when he was angry
that he shouldn't have and um
for right now we're not gonna we're not
gonna be able to see him
and let that be that makes sense okay so
we're gonna keep it very fast for your
friends very surface level what we're
not gonna do is go into 18 hours of
um
explanations and we love you and
we're going to demonstrate that love
through touch through hey let's go get
some dinner we're going to go out where
do you want to eat give him some
uh this is really important give him a
moment of choice because you know what
you're going to give him when everything
he just lost control you're going to
give him a tiny tiny piece of control
back
okay so where do you want to go eat and
more importantly where do you want to
get ice cream after we eat
all right and whose hand do you want to
hold mine or dad's
his dad's hands are huge but they're
scratchy and moms are soft well you get
to pick which one and so we're going to
right we're going to what music do you
want to listen to in the car and he may
say nothing he may go silent he may go
he may have experienced this before
maybe you ask him that question have you
ever experienced dad when he got very
very angry was it scary
and if he says no never then great cool
that may or may not be true but we're
giving him tiny pieces of control back
in little pockets
and it's going to settle his sweet
little eight yards eight-year-old soul
down a tiny bit
i don't think that i would mention right
now
without the presence of a counselor
that it was his sisters that got beat up
okay because he is going to then be
about trying to i've got to be with my
sisters and now you've got a whole other
thing going on
okay my guess is he's had to protect
them before
ah
okay and he may need to see sisters by
the way and if y'all can make that
happen in any shape form or fashion make
it happen
okay take them all to the movies
whatever but he may need to put eyes on
them and i wouldn't uh i wouldn't take
that from him if at all possible if the
courts allow that but great great
question so i rambled a lot at you
here's the old ultimate underlying
things in a summary facts are your
friends
state it clearly age appropriately in a
way that he can understand but do it in
a context of touch
somebody's holding one hand mom's you've
got your hand on the back of his neck
that he feels safe
because his body's gonna take off on him
ask him has this ever happened to you
before do you know have you ever seen
daddy get angry
and if he doesn't want to answer that
great cool
the third thing is here's what we're
going to do now you're safe here with us
and then we're going to um sisters are
going to stay with some folks right now
and they're going to keep her them safe
and they're going to be
loving and where do you want to go eat
okay and then we're going to go from
there okay
all right kyle uh i take back all the
mean things i said about oklahomans
you've you've done your you've done your
your cost because you've done your
country well you've done your state well
um
man this we're this
your kids are lucky to have you brother
and the community's likely to have you
in it
to everybody listening if there are kids
in your world whether they're your kids
or others
and they show up with bruises you stop
everything cancel everything
and make the calls we'll be right back
big secret
almost all of us can control our
thoughts
yes you can control your thoughts you
choose them most people believe thoughts
randomly happen and that we have to give
rent free space to bad thoughts and
scary thoughts and freaky thoughts this
is not true
our world doesn't want you to know this
because they want the privilege of
owning your mind no more i want to teach
you how to take back your thoughts
if you often find yourself lost in a
tornado of toxic thoughts and anxiety
and always on high alert you'll have to
be intentional about changing your
thoughts but it is 100
possible in my new book own your past
change your future we'll walk through a
not so complicated approach to mental
health and wellness that includes
learning how to reject harmful thoughts
and cultivate thoughts that move you
closer to who you want to be so go to
johndaloni.com to take the next step
towards wellness that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
this song is for the great
and lovely and kind and incredibly
good-looking
senior associate executive czar blake
thompson his favorite band of all time
rem
shout out it's the end of the world as
we know it and i feel fine and it goes
like this that's great
starts with an earthquake birds and
snakes an airplane and lenny bruce he's
not afraid i have a hurricane listen to
yourself churn world serves its own
needs don't miss serve your own needs
speed it up a notch speed grunt no
strength the ladder starts to clatter
with fear of height down height wire in
a fire representing seven games i don't
know what that means and a government
for a higher in a combat site left of
west and coming in a hurry with the
furies breathing down your neck
and a bunch of other words spoken really
fast it's the end of the world as we
know it it's the end of the world as we
know it
and i feel fine and i hope you do too
we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode students
are
you know zoning out really fast the
phones are coming out they're watching
videos texting friends listening to
music after two years three years of
absolute complete and total isolation
that phone
has become their heartbeat are you
nervous about being a military wife yes
so have you sat down and had an honest
conversation with
a military wife about that world that
life
no actually you should probably do that